ich habe heute das thema
wettbewerbsfähigkeit mitgebracht denn
fakt ist deutschland verliert jeden tag
an wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseren
wirtschaftsstandort verliert jeden tag
an wettbewerbsfähigkeit und ich vertrete
über sechseinhalb 1000 familien
unternehmen darunter 1500 junge
unternehmer in deutschland und wir
machen uns große sorgen weil genau diese
themen nicht angepackt werden wir
brauchen einen neuen turbo im thema
klimapolitik in der digitalisierung wir
brauchen infrastruktur wir haben das
enorme problem des fachkräftemangels wir
haben eine untersuchung eine befragung
bei unseren familienunternehmern
durchgeführt zwei drittel der
familienunternehmer sagen dass die
größte sorge der fachkräftemangel ist
also wir müssen doch da wirklich jetzt
mal anpacken das erwarten wir auch von
seiten der jungunternehmer von der ampel
das erwarten wir auch von der fdp und
ihren neuen freunden die sie jetzt haben
wir müssen wirklich schaue ich mal
christian lindner hat ja jetzt den
ersten schritt in richtung startups
gemacht das ist gut aber wir brauchen
auch weitere verbesserungen der
rahmenbedingungen wir brauchen weniger
bürokratie wir brauchen ein tag dieser
für fachkräfte wir brauchen
unterstützung dass wir hier in
deutschland entlastet werden als
unternehmen und das ist wirklich eine
priorität und ich gerichtet an die union
würde ich mir tatsächlich auch wünschen
dass diese selbstbewusster auftritt dass
sie auch konkrete forderungen richtet an
die regierung und dass sie auch wirklich
klartext redet es ist eine große chance
für union und fdp zusammen hier auch
stark die wirtschaftspolitischen themen
voranzutreiben das finde ich haben sie
vollkommen recht und gleichzeitig legen
sie den finger in eine eine weitere
wunde die glaube ich wieder zu tun hat
mit dem vertrauensproblem es ist
vermutlich sogar in der fdp und in der
union inzwischen und sagen zu wenig
wirtschaftliches know-how vertreten
durch menschen die mit ihrer biografie
dafür tatsächlich stehen man kann viel
lesen und man kann sich viele
untersuchungen angucken und und kann
versuchen betriebe zu besuchen und sich
zu informieren aber das ist dann doch
immer an gelerntes wissen so zu sagen
leute die wirklich aus dem bereich
selber kommen und die nöte und sorgen
kennen die müssten sie eigentlich auch
direkt in die politik einspeisen kann
was wir aber beobachten und das gilt für
die union auf jeden fall wenn ich die
letzte untersuchung die ich dazu gelesen
habe nicht nicht völlig falsch erinnere
es gibt eine ganz starke tendenz zur
selbstregulierung bei den parteien das
heißt immer öfter wird der mitarbeiter
des abgeordneten dann abgeordneter das
ist im ersten moment wahrscheinlich auch
plausibel weil der versteht viel davon
gemacht hat das ist vielleicht besser
als alle anderen bewerber von außen aber
wie soll da sozusagen der der familie
der wirklichen der verantwortung und
auch noch was anderes zu tun hat
sozusagen überhaupt sich diesem diesem
ritual unterwerfen dagegen ankommen und
dann diese zeit in parteien verbringen
wir brauchen irgend eine intelligente
lösung wie sie entweder ihre leute oder
das wirtschaftspolitische know-how
stärker also wie sie das besser in viel
zu suchen wir ja das problem ist wir
haben tatsächlich viele berufspolitiker
und wenig wirtschaftskompetenz in der
politik und wir jetzt als auch als
verband die familienunternehmer die
jungunternehmer wir reden uns den mund
fusselig sie kritisieren nicht nur
sondern wir erarbeiten auch
lösungsvorschläge tragen die der politik
vorgeben ihnen unsere lösungsvorschläge
wie es laufen kann damit die wirtschaft
auch weiter in zukunft entlastet wird
aber manchmal habe ich das gefühl das
geht da rein und da raus leider und es
wird die dann kommt nicht richtig machen
und es ist problem wir als unternehmer
sind macher umsätze und das fehlt mir
tatsächlich in der
innenpolitik gehe das duo gerne was
friedrich merz ist ja nun gerade das
gegenbeispiel und wenn ich mir anschaue
wie auch der neue bundesvorstand der cdu
zusammen gesetzt da sind auch einige
wirklich treffen nicht annehmen
ein unternehmen aufgebaut und geführt ja
aber hat viel wirtschaftserfahrung ja an
seinem lebenslauf gesammelt das muss man
glaube ich schon sagen und ich glaube
auch ganz wichtig ist der punkt also ich
könnte jetzt auch sagen beschwert euch
nicht bei mir ich hab cdu gewählt ja im
moment ist es ja jetzt nicht die cdu die
im bund regiert leider aber ich glaube
dass auch der punkt infrastrukturausbau
noch ein ganz wichtiger ist und da muss
ich sagen bin ich auch überrascht wie
schnell die fdp umgekippt ist als erstes
fiel die technologieoffen offenheit beim
elektroauto hinten rüber jetzt werden
auch projekte aus dem
bundesverkehrswegeplan wieder in frage
gestellt und so weiter also ich weiß
nicht ob diese partnerschaft mit der fdp
mit der ampel fdp so gut funktioniert
aber wir haben uns das vorgenommen ich
glaube dass auch teil der inhaltlichen
neuaufstellung der zehn mal dass wir da
wieder folgen
robitaille orten ein absolut das heißt
auch die fdp darf jetzt nicht umkippen
muss festhalten an dem thema es auch
proaktiv themen setzen
marktwirtschaftliche
wirtschaftspolitische themen aber ich
glaube auch dass die union unglaubliche
chance er hat jetzt mit solchen stimmen
von außen kritisch zu beobachten laut zu
sein klartext zu sprechen weil die
kombination aus union fdp kann wirklich
etwas bewirken für die wirtschaft und
habe ich große hoffnung weil sagen dass
gerade unsere nur eine einzige
überträger ist ja gerade unseren
finanzminister christa länder nach paris
begleitet wie war dein eindruck von ihm
also wird er jetzt das ist ja immer nach
vorne also ich finde es klasse dass er
gerade in diesem bereich start-ups und
gründer thum unternehmertum wirklich
auch macht also hat sich wirklich dieses
projekt angenommen er ist nach paris er
hat dort einen star eu startup fonds mit
frankreich gegründet und es ist ein
gutes signal ein starkes signal das
brauchen wir auch weil das thema ist er
wirklich in deutschland wir feiern das
unternehmertum zu wenig wir brauchen
mehr gründer und ersetzt wirklich ein
starkes signal und das ist wirklich auch
mal machen das finde ich gut und positiv
das wird ja jetzt alles viel besser
werden denn wenn die mode um sich greift
das man lobbyisten direkt auf seine
kosten dann wird demnächst bestimmt der
bdi-chef oder andere verbände werden da
ganz groß zum tragen kommen und oder
sieben
mal interessant mit ermittler jenny
jenny morgen oder übermorgen die wurde
er von annalena baerbock jetzt auf diese
position gehoben aber eigentlich ist
doch die position von annalena baerbock
außenministerin zu sein wir haben doch
wirklich so viele probleme gerade
draußen ja eigentlich sollte sie sich
doch darum kümmern wenn ich dachte
robert habeck ist ein fürs klima und
wirtschaft verantwortlich und dass sie
jetzt auf einmal also ich bin ja
wirklich das außen die außen
klimaverhandlungen hat ausdrücklich sie
sich ins als kompetenz ins haus geholt
das ist ein ganz cleverer schachzug der
die die grünen gemacht haben sie haben
nahezu alle klima kompetenzen bei sich
gebündelt vor allem die auf europäischer
ebene das fällt vielen nicht auf ist
auch relativ unerotisch weil die
brüsseler dinge schwer zu durchschauen
sind alles was man dort fest zonen kann
zum beispiel bei der taxonomie
führt dazu dass es später in nationales
recht umgesetzt werden muss oder aber
direkt auf unser wirtschaften wirkt also
wenn wir in brüssel durchsetzen eine
bestimmte solar quote dann kommt die
irgendwann zu uns nur niemand bemerkt
weil wenn in brüssel was beschlossen
wird kriegt dass keiner mit und fünf
jahre später müssen wir es einführen das
ist relativ clever und man spielt dann
über wandel in brüssel und das haben
sich die grünen ganz gut gesichert und
frau berbalk hat die internationalen
aber die kompetenzen das macht ja noch
schlimmer also wenn die lobbyistin sogar
noch ins zuständige ministerium kommt
und quasi also direkt im rahmen ihres
lobbyverein stan politik machen kann ja
auch dazu das jetzt irgendwie noch die
staatsbürgerschaft
man muss man aber vor allem das ist ja
auch eine organisation die zuletzt vor
allem durch kriminelle und hoch
gefährliche aktionen aufgefallen und sie
sollten aufhören sollte aufhören dass
ich am reichstag abzuseilen oder oder
farben sperren auszuschütten in berlin
das käme nicht gut in ihrem staatsamt
das andere problem ist aber wenn jemand
dergestalt lobbyist sich vor geprägt ist
bei diesem klima verhandlungen auf
internationaler ebene ich weiß nicht wer
sich doch mal rein gezogen hat die
gesamte kopenhagener klimakonferenz
mitgemacht das nicht
vergnügungssteuerpflichtig das ist ein
teppichhandel ohne ende und da kommt es
darauf an sich auch nicht über den tisch
ziehen zu lassen von anderen ländern nur
weil klima einfach eine tolle sache ist
und da habe ich ein bisschen bedenken
denn es ist ein hohes maß auch ein
eigeninteresse dabei dass man versucht
jedes halbe prozent co2 sich anzurechnen
über permafrostböden über stäube die
über der sahara aufgetrieben werden und
nach lateinamerika waren im co2 senken
aufforstung jeder möchte sich möglichst
viel an rechnen und da muss man eben
auch als unterhändler ganz klar sagen
dass sich nicht andere leute alles an
rechnen können und wir sind dann
diejenigen die es bezahlen wenn die
tonga inseln untergehen machen wir schon
machen wir auch zu recht aber es muss
ein fairer anteil sein und sind alle
mitmachen und dieses taffe verhandeln
darf nicht durch einen gag klima ist
eine tolle sache wir geben alles
mentalität da habe ich ein bisschen
bedenken dass deutsche interessen da
unter die räder kommen wenn so eine
hochkarätige lobbyisten dann sitzt was
die fachkompetenz im bundestag betrifft
ist übrigens ganz interessant wenn man
ein paar jahre dabei ist und sich mit
abgeordneten unterhält man stellt immer
wieder fest dass diejenigen die einen
beruf gelernt habe oder aus dem beruf im
bundestag gekommen sind ein ganz anderes
politikverständnis haben viel
pragmatischer viel detaillierter und und
realist aber deswegen müsse es auch die
möglichkeit geben für quereinsteiger als
ich kenne unternehmerinnen und
unternehmer die wirklich sagen würden
also ich tue das auch jetzt an ich
krempeln die ärmel hoch und ich gehen
die politik gemacht so schwierig macht
die parteiführung tatsächlich das wohl
hin und sagen das machen wir uns das
förderwesen funktioniert nur wenn es von
oben gefördert wird und solange es noch
einen einzigen normalen bewerber in
jedweder man eingibt wird er sagen das
ist gar nicht nur durch wir haben ja
noch eigene tolle leute also wir machen
doch jetzt hier keinen platz freuen